في السنوات الماضيه لجا الراغبون في
التبرع باعضائهم بعد الوفاه الى مصلحه
الشهر العقاريه لتحرير توكيلات يوثقون
فيها رغبتهم لكنهم واجهوا صعوبات كثيره
ومتاعب جمه
2018 رحت اعمل توكيل في الشهر العقاري
لقيت صعوبه شديده جدا من الموظفين عدم كل
الموظفين يدوا لبعض الورقه كده بعد ما
يقروا انا عايز اعمل ايه ويقولوا لي ما
عملناش ما عملناش ما ينفعش
ما ينفعش خالص عننا الشهر العقاري اصلا
موظفين مش عارفين اصلا ومش عارفين ايه
اللي انا باطلبه ده وفاكرين ان انا احد
جاي يضيع
الموضوع ده مش مشكلتي انا مشكله في رقم
قانون انا جايه عشان اوسخ الرقم القانون
اني من حقي اوصف الميه مستني المدير غير
المدير رفض برده يعمليه ورحت لشهر العقاري
بتاع ال- اا
المحكمه
وسخت بس بعد كده نسرحوا نفس الفرع ورفضت
وانا رحت معاهم
تقريبا طردتنا فلما وريته من القانون برده
رافضين جدا لغايه ما اللي كان عارف قانون
هو مدير الشهر العقاري
فقلت له وهو كان تمام برحم كل حاجه بس ما
كانش عارف مين اللي ممكن يساعدني فيهم لان
هم ما عندهمش علم خالص ولا كان عندهم
الفرن اصلا بتاعه الاقرار الاسبوع الماضي
همم
دكتور خالد عبد الغفار وزير الصحه السكان
كان هناك منشور او كتاب دوري لي كل همم
اماكن الشهر العقاري همم العمل القرارات
او تفيد لكنه اللي جايه يتبرع بعضو بعد
الوفايا يستطيع ان ان يوثق ذلك في الشهر
العقاري